members
good morning members of the public
you're all very welcome to this meeting
of baby district council's planning
committee meeting of
today 23rd september
may i first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements
please ensure that the microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you wish to speak point of order
declare and or interest or request in
the german
please use the hands up function
on the taskbar members are reminded
they should not have alternative
communication lines
open i.e other skype chats
and that if you are contacted by a third
party during the application
you should bring this to the legal
advisor's attention
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
if members do lose connection to the
meeting
that they must contact the member
support officer
mandy smith as soon as possible
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential and accept
items if you do make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be and
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council
and to the possible use of those same
recordings for webcast and
or training purposes the council
members of the public and press may
record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
we have mark russell area planning
manager
jamie wayne wayne up case officer
lawyer and robert carmichael governance
officer
can i now move to the agenda
the item number one apologies for
absence
i'll asked robert if you would take us
through the roll call for members
present please
thank you chair i'll just do a roll call
for members so if you could please
respond
um with your uh with other good morning
or present please so councillor sue
ayers
good morning council melanie barrett
good morning
councillor peter beer present
councillor david busby president casa
john hinton
president council lee jameson rolling
castle mary mclaren present council
adrian osborne
good morning present council allison
owen good morning
council lee parker present counselor
stephen plum
president and we have the award members
with us today of councillor jane gould
good morning councilman margaret mabry
good morning and counselor clyde harty
good morning thank you chair we are all
present and i believe just for clarity
as well that the two public speakers
um are here this morning for the first
item of robin coates
um from worst parish council and uh
sarah cornwell as the um representative
um
applicant agent on the first item thank
you chair
thank you very much right we'll move to
item two with declarations of
any members interest do i have any
members
no hands are up so i'll take that as
snow
okay thank you we'll move to item
three to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 9th of
september um are there any points of
clarity
they were sent out yesterday well the
day before i believe
no you're all okay can i have a proposal
please followed by a
i propose peter um
that's uh yes and seconded by
suez yourself adrian osborne hey dream
i was born lee jensen and adrian osborne
thank you very much right i'll ask
robert to do a roll call again
so if you could please respond with
fought against or abstain
so councillor suez four
councilor melanie barrett abstain
because i haven't seen them
counselor peter beer four
that's the dave busby four
counselor john hinton well
councillor lee jameson for
counseling mary mclaren paul councillor
adrian osborne
councillor alison owen um abstain as i
wasn't here
casa lee parker paul
and councillor stephen plum four
thank you chair that's carried thank you
very much the minutes will be signed at
the next practical
opportunity okay members thank you
we'll move on to item number five which
is to receive notifications of any
petitions uh
rob can you compare none received
thank you very much item six site
inspections
again i know we can't have them at the
moment we all know why
but i have to ask officers are there any
site inspection requests
no check thank you and members are there
any site inspection requests
no thank you very much
all right then we'll move on to item 6a
which is planning applications
which we've taken it in the following
order um
[Music]
right we'll conduct field west of bourne
hill
western suffolk case officer
well i think it's on page 11
jamie wine up okay
thank you chair and good morning members
um i'm just going to share
my screen with you just give me a couple
of seconds my screen keep learning
better
it's coming back i don't quite know
what's happening but carry on i'm with
you
can everyone see my screen yes yep
brilliant um so i'll be presenting
dc200701 to you today
the site is klondike field westerborn
hill in worsted
the application is a reserve matters
application for the erection of 75
dwellings and the discharge of
conditions that were from the outlying
permission
um you saw the application first in
august and it was deferred and the
reasons for this
i'll go through in later slides but
first i'll
recap and start with some context on it
um i'd particularly draw members
attention to pages 18
and 20 well 18 to 20 of the committee
report
and paragraph 4 to 4.15
which discusses the reasons for deferral
so the site is outlined in red here
and the orange line just for context
shows the boundary between baber and
ipswich
then we've got a zoomed in aerial map so
the dwellings
are located to the north bit the field
here
this southern bit it will be um changed
from a private to public woodland
but this was approved um under the
hybrid application which was the
original which i'll go on to in a little
while
um the star shows with the accesses onto
bon terrace along here and it's accessed
via bourne hill
this is not a reserve matter as it was
approved outline
you've then got the row of dwellings
along bourne hill
which sort of indicates where the
settlement boundary is
um you've then got pod redux kinder care
and a cluster of dwellings
sort of to the western side and the a137
running west and north
so in terms of planning history in 2018
a hybrid application was submitted and
outline planning permission was granted
for the erection of 75 dwellings which
included the access
um and a full application well full
planning permission was granted for the
change of use
from the private woodland to community
woodland so that has been dealt with
previously um you've then got the
section
106 legal agreement which was signed
alongside this which
um secured rams contributions affordable
housing provision
and public open space
um so these conditions were the ones
that were on the outline permission
um and are included in the development
description of this
reserve matters to um discharge
it's worth noting that these are not
reserved matters
and could be dealt separately but have
been included
for completeness
um so in terms of this application it
was deferred by members on the 29th of
august
it was primarily deferred for reasons of
a lack of pepper potting of the
affordable housing
the open market housing mix where
members sought to
have more bungalows and smaller homes
you wanted to see some increased
sustainability measures
a change in pathway materials along the
eastern boundary of the site
increased immunity space around the
apartments
and uh boundary treatment details along
the a137
um in order to stop people cutting
through
um so i'll discuss the amendments that
have been made to address these issues
um in the following slides but firstly
i'll just recap on the site and scheme
so there's a public right way running
west of the site and again sort of north
east of the site as well there are
three grade two listed buildings so
there's a public house uh
sort of the north east and a set of
um semi-detached dwellings just to the
south-east
and there are two uh tpo's as well
on site
um so the main thing from this map is
really the flood zone this is flood zone
two just running here
um it's primarily north and outside of
the site but there's a very small
proportion that comes within the site
um it's worth noting that this coincides
with a condition that was put on the
outline for a no
build zone so there will not be any
dwellings
sort of in the northern area here in
terms
in terms of the ecology matters um
the site is within an area that triggers
ram's contributions which as i've said
earlier
was secured at the outline
so i've got some photos along bourne
hill
so the first one looks northwards along
bourne hill and towards ipswich
and you can see that you've got the
dwellings either side
number two shows the approved access
point onto bourne terrace
which again was approved outline and
this will be appropriately upgraded
under the conditions of the outline
permission
and just to reiterate is not a reserve
matter
um and then photos three and four show
the rear of the dwellings
a long um born heel so you can see
there's a range of boundary treatments
from fencing no fencing hedgerow trees
and also you can see a mixture of
bungalows and two-story dwellings as
well
then you've got some other photos these
are taken within the site
so the first one shows where bourne
terrace
the access road is you've then got the
main site
here um you can see that there is sort
of this informal grassland pathway
running here
this coincides with the eastern pathway
on the application
and the reserve matters application that
is and
um then you've got photo number three
which looks through the car park of um
puddle duck kinder care
um and the frontage as well so you can
see the site is through here as you can
see there's sort of fencing along here
and some trees which progressively get
thicker
as you go towards the west and the rear
of the site
so one of the first reasons this
application was previously deferred
um was based on the open market mix
where members were seeking bungalows and
smaller homes
there's been no change to the housing
mix from what was previously presented
to members
however it is crucial to note we cannot
dictate the mix at this stage
as it should have been secured outline
it would be unlawful for us to do so at
this stage
and again i would reiterate that the
emerging joint local plan policy
um specifically for bungalows um whilst
it holds limited weight
does show some sort of direction and
seeks
three percent um of the total dwellings
to be bungalows
this application does provide that
another reason that the application was
deferred was based on the affordable
housing
and distribution and specifically the
pepper potting
so the application now has
three clusters so cluster one here
is four dwellings cluster two is
thirteen dwellings and cluster three
is nine dwellings including the
apartment block
all clusters are therefore now under the
15 dwelling threshold
and they are all accessed via different
access roads in
again the affordable houses remain
tenure-blind including on materials and
architectural features so
you will not know that they're there um
the sustainability measures were another
reason that members deferred the
application
they have been discharged through a
condition that was imposed on the
outline
this condition was for the submission of
a sustainability statement
these measures have been assessed by the
council's environmental management
officer
and as i say they have previously been
discharged and therefore have been
sorted
um many of the required sustainability
measures
it's worth noting are secured through
building regulations so that will be to
do with
your double glazing things like that and
efficiency of homes
and there will also be cycle storage
provided on site
as well as electric vehicle charging
points in the garages
um and then we've got the the
landscaping features of the site so
there's sort of three different reasons
here
um that this addresses for the previous
reasons for deferral
so you've got the a137 boundary along
here
so they will be repairing the existing
post and rail fence
including an anti-climb galvanized steel
in
certain areas as well and the hedgerow
will be retained
and also thickened in areas where there
were gaps
um it's also worth noting that this is a
condition
to be discharged um so could be dealt
with outside of the reserve matters
application
and is assessed by suffolk county
council highways so they are looking
at ensuring that no one is crossing um
the a137
unsafely um then you've got the the
pathway along the eastern boundary
this pathway was previously gravel and
has been changed to a trail flex
surface which has been used elsewhere
for wheelchairs push chairs cyclists
and it's permeable it's even and
it retains a high standard of design
suitable for the development
finally you've got the amenity space
around the flats
this has been increased and also
a hedgerow has been included
to both demarcate and screen the amenity
area
then you've got the story heights under
the reserve matters so just going back
to the point of bungalows
so predominantly you've got the
two-story dwellings you've got
single-story garages
and the bungalows and a two-story and
three-story apartment block
as you can see the existing dwellings
along
um bourne hill are a mixture of heights
um from one story to two story um
there is no strong character or pattern
for bungalows along there
there's no residential amenity issues
that are rising um
from two-story dwellings along the
eastern edge
as you can see there are quite
significant separation distances between
them
and again along the western boundary
adjacent to puddle docks kinder care
um there would be a bungalow and
two-story
terraced dwellings um there's a
separation distance here of between
eight and 11 meters and actually you've
got
some existing and proposed hedgerow and
further screening along that boundary
to mitigate any overlooking
so my recommendation is therefore to
grant this reserve matters application
with conditions thank you for listening
thank you um i'll see if there's any
uh points that members would like
clarify by you
um can i just ask you to repeat again
regarding the mix which was the
fundamental one i believe
as to why we can't still stand
firm on that um because i think
our officers are looking into how we can
secure an outlining
future uh the mixed question
um of um the prevalence
but can you just confirm that point
because we don't want to get bogged down
on that
if there is nothing we can do about it
yes so
um as i say there's been no change to
the housing mix from what was previously
presented
and although it's acknowledged that
members sought more bungalows and
smaller homes
um aligned with the local need as this
is a reserve matters application um it's
unlawful
for us at this stage to um
you know impose any further restriction
on the housing mix
that wasn't secured outline um so as you
say we are looking
at ways that we can um ensure members
are aware of this out the out at
the outline stage um which may be
through imposing a
sort of suitable condition thank you yes
i think
officers have got the message that if
this sort of thing happens again
we need to have them to highlight that
to us at outlying
um but before i take any questions um
ian did you want to comment on that last
point that's our legal opposer
no in
sorry i was muted chairman i do
apologize i just i just wanted to come
in briefly to confirm that i agree with
lu
with jasmine it would be i'm afraid it
would be unlawful to
um to go beyond the the parameters of
the the outline in that in that context
and as jasmine says we will bear that in
mind in the future
but i that's all i need to say thank you
uh councillor busby followed by
councillor hinton
thanks chair i understand that we're not
allowed to impose anything but i
just want to understand myself the
decision-making process that the
developers taken into determining
what houses they're going to have and i
therefore like to
ask the officer she stressed the point
in her report 4.4 the question therefore
is not what was intended at the time of
the decision
but what a reasonable reader would
understand was permitted
by the local planning authority how
would
a reasonable reader understand what was
required
and at what stage was dennis would that
be done
uh ch chair chair may i come in here
uh yes that's mark brussels yeah the
words in italics there were taken from a
council opinion on this
matter on a different site obviously
but the point is that when we get to the
reserve matters stage
we can't introduce another reserve
matter
um which in this case would be the
housing mix
unless we'd explicitly flagged up an
outline either by saying
explicitly there shall be ten bungalows
for example or saying
the matter of mix shall be looked at at
reserve matters it wasn't flagged up
although
the app the original outline applicant
did have a nice drawing showing
rows of bungalows which one could argue
was a little bit naughty
if one presumed that's what was going to
go to reserve matters the
the legal piece of paper does not have
anything saying that the purchaser of
the land has got to put
a row of bungalows there and all they've
got is a permission
an outline permission for 75 houses with
those
reserve matters reserved so we cannot
bring in a new reserve matter now
yeah i understand that but what i'm
trying to establish is
what discussions amongst themselves the
developer would have
to decide on what the market mix would
be and what responsibility
would they have for trying to comply
with law
and with the local policies that's what
i'm after
not what we can do we can't do at what
point
did the developer decide that they were
going to go for all housing and no
bungalows along that stretch
and why and it says
what the reason would be was permitted
by the local planning authority so that
implies that the local planning
authority must have had some input into
that
and in fact the nppf actually still
spells out that we have to it says under
72c
that we should set clear expectations
for the quality of the development
and how this can be maintained and
ensure that a variety of homes
to meet the needs of different groups in
the community will be provided
and if that's not enough the schma which
we all use as the bible
spells out exactly what the percentage
of houses should be
so i'm just trying to establish at what
point the developer made the decision to
ignore
all of this available device uh
information
okay uh councillor busby i've allowed
you to make those points
quite rightly because i do want this
point cleared up at the beginning
because we don't want to be bogged down
on this so
um mark with the help of your um
yes i'm not aware that there was any um
participation from from council officers
before the reserve matters was submitted
um so um i think that's that basically
the they purchased it from the outline
permission owners
and have pursued this scheme so that's
what they've done you you'd have to ask
the app the applicant
why they've gone for this mix we can't
you know we can't answer for them
but the brief answer is that these
matters need to be sorted out outlined
yeah and i think the point members which
we must remember
and hopefully the officers will on our
behalf also
that we need to make sure that in
outline we do
question the mix if that's appropriate
um right any other questions um there's
no other hands up so i'm assuming
there's no one else got any points of
clarification
well you did mention me mr chairman yes
i did your hand was up but has
disappeared but
uh councillor hinton if you have
something to ask well i agree with
everything that the
the councillor busby has said but i'm a
little bit confused when it says on page
11
has the application been subject to
pre-application advice
yes yes so we obviously gave them some
advice and we obviously didn't give
them enough advice about the mix of
housing so but
rather than as you say dwell on that
point any further
uh i would just like to sort of know
exactly what is in all the conditions
that's 8 11 16 18
28 31 32 and 33 of the outline approval
because these
conditions are being put on by officers
are then being discharged under the
discretionary powers of officers
and yet uh the members of this committee
are not getting any sort of say in what
is
is put on there or done or anything else
that's the first point and the other
point is that it does say within the
consultation
reports highways minor amendments
required see relevant section below
relevant section below does not exist in
our report so i'd like to know what
those minor
amendments were these are questions to
the officers so i would let them
go mark and just mean if you'd like to
take them between you
uh yes i suppose i can start with the um
the highways bits um so in terms of the
conditions that highways are they're
seeking very
it's not really amendments it's very
minor clarifications between
and they are discussions between the
developer and suffolk county council
highways
um they're not you know anything in
principle that's wrong with them
um it's just very minor clarifications
on for example on the um the boundary
with the a137
um it's a case of clarifying
you know the material and the look of
the galvanized steel it's that sort of
specific detail um
so that hopefully answers that point um
in terms of the
conditions um i can probably get them
up but you might have to bear with me
just a little while while i get the
specific wording if that's something
that you wanted to see
um in terms of the
uh i suppose the delegated
aspect of the conditions i think that's
something that i would ask mark
um to maybe answer that point
yes thanks um i mean i i do completely
understand what council hinton's saying
i mean
what it seems like it's sort of not fair
members don't get to contribute to that
but
the permission was granted outline back
in i think it was early 2019
and part of that permission was
the imposition of conditions and the
conditions are delegated to officers at
the moment under this current scheme of
delegation
so hopefully hopefully that answers the
question council hinton
thank you um i think jasmine if if those
um points that councillor hinton want to
answer you've got to look up perhaps you
can bring them up when we get to debate
and i'll go to councillor hinton first
okay it's fine or have you got them
um i haven't at hand but it shouldn't
take me too long to find them so
i should have them in time for that yeah
lovely
okay thank you uh councillor adrian
uh council osborne
yeah thank you thank you mr chairman i'm
sorry about that got a bit mixed up with
the buttons there
um i just uh just like a bit of
clarification
um on the drawing of the housing
um the uh what we're regarding is pepper
potting around
the site um can we
could we see the um that uh slide again
so
and just identify where this pepper
potting is for
social and affordable housing do you
know what number slide it was
afraid it went past me too quickly right
that's fine i can i can find it bear
with me
the reason for asking that is that on
previous applications we've had
reasons for doing this because of the
way that they are maintained
and it's easier to have them all in one
place are they going for that again on
this
side um that
again is probably something i would ask
the developer
in terms of maintenance um but
it is something that has come up in the
past certainly
yeah okay uh council osborne put it
through the applicant when he
and i wasn't speaks who to ask on that
one thank you
we've got the officer's view and then we
can get the applicants
um there's no other hands up members so
i'm going to move on
we now move to the public speakers we
have the parish council robin coats
you sir have three minutes in which to
address the committee rob will you start
the time when
um robin starts speaking over to you sir
good morning can you say and hear me
okay can't see you yet
right now i can see you and we can hear
you okay
good morning good morning thank you very
much for the opportunity to speak this
morning um
i don't wish to retread the ground
you've just been over but i do think
there is one important clarification
from the parish point of view the
officers report on these reserve matters
states that they consider enforcing the
original condition
specified at the time of outline and
which details the sixteen bungalows
will be placing an extra limitation on
the applicant and would be illegal
we do not believe that's the case this
is not an extra limitation
it's the enforcement of the original
outline condition condition 4.
this is actually reinforced by the
planning officer who confirms in her
report power 4
2 the only matters which can be
considered following the grant of an
outline permission
are those that have been made subject of
a condition which
is the case here condition 4 of the
outline permission which has 16
bungalows
states that the reserve matters must be
in general conformity with this design
reducing the number of bungalows from 16
down to 3 as belway are trying to do
is an 80 reduction in the number of
bungalows
and i cannot see any way this can be
considered in being general conformity
with the original outline approval
worsted parish council therefore request
that the original outline planning
permission in condition 4 be enforced
it's the original condition and beltway
implement the original site plan with 16
bungalows
and ensure that the new construction to
the rear of the existing homes on bourne
hill
be single story that's all we've got to
comment on this morning so
thank you very much for your time thank
you mr coats
um i'm going to go straight to the legal
advisor first i asked um
about condition for the enforcement of
the 16 bungalows so we can clear that
point up
um i'm here i'm here chairman yes i'm
happy to assist you but
it might help if to set the context
before i speak if the officers go first
because i know they
they've got something more direct to say
on this precise point i believe okay
i'll i'll get the officers to answer
first and then i'll come to you after
they've spoken uh
mark jasmine which one uh condition
four which um mr coats relates to uh
refers to
uh does speak of general conformity and
i think if
if we're able to look at the the
presentation again it might help
um but maybe not but anyway that the
layout does generally conform with that
drawing
um albeit that it's not bungalows it's
two-story dwellings um the layout
generally does conform with that drawing
so
we're content that it conforms
would it be of assistance um i have a
slide that i didn't show you but i
is on my presentation if that's helpful
where it compares the two
yes please yeah go with me just one
second
so this was the um the outline
and when it talks about condition four
and to do with general conformity
there is nothing on here that indicates
bungalows so when we talk about
general conformity with that um
with the outline um condition
this is fully in general conformity with
that layout
there is nothing to indicate bungalows
on here at all unfortunately
right thank you ian is there anything
i'm here yeah i'm unmuted now hopefully
yes or i mean i don't need i don't
believe in over complicating things
my colleagues are right i note the
parish council's disappointment but
jasmine has put it very succinctly and i
don't need to elaborate
thank you very much right members uh
i can say councillor busby you've got
your hand up
yes chair just taking those two um
slides
the slightest questions too sorry this
is questions to the
parish council um represented fine i
have a question tim um
robin what consultation did the
developer have
with the parish um
so i trust you can see and hear me now
so the consultation originally would
have been with the
uh the applicant for the outline
permission which was pidgin
um pidgin work great labors and i except
it's not recorded in the documentation
there but it were great uh
um went to great lengths to stress to us
that um
they would put bungalows down the rear
housing the existing homes on bourne
hill
because they were concerned that this
would be an area where potentially
people could be overlooked a lot of
light etc
so to try and help with the community uh
and create a development that would be
better for
everybody in uh involved they would put
bungalows down there so it was a point
they made
and stressed quite quite extensively to
us uh
and the dog the diagram that we've just
been shown of the housing um
the accompanying information that was
shown to the parish at the time
told us that they were bungalows um now
it may be
that's not been carried forward into
that drawing i i would go i would defer
to jasmine for that
but specifically we were told there
would be bungalows but what about
railway what what uh discussions have
they had with the parish
uh we met with bellew once we met with
uh sarah cornwell who's here with us
this morning
um and went through uh through the
revised plan that she had
i have copies of it here in my office
and that showed the
the change from bungalows to two-story
dwellings and i know that was raised
with her at the time by various
residents
it was also raised by various residents
and the parish
in our comments to the reserve matters
thank you
okay thank you thank you councillor
busby
any other questions to the parish
council
there's no hands up so i'll take that as
not
thank you mr coats we'll now move on
uh we don't have an objector or
supporter
so i'll now ask the agent to speak sarah
cornwell
you have three minutes to address the
committee um
when you're ready rob when they're ready
would you start the clock
thank you thank you
uh good morning members and thank you
for allowing me to speak again
as you're aware i'm the planner for
beltway homes i'll stop you there a
moment we can't see you i don't know
whether you wanted to be seen but
we can't see you at the moment says my
camera's on
no my video's not working hang on no i
think you might just have to hear me
yeah you know that's that's fine if
you're
rob did you want to say something
due to connection issues so it's not on
issue as long as you're happy chair and
um
sarah is happy as well yeah sarah if you
can't make the video work then
um we can hear you so you can carry on
when you're done
yeah thank you uh
yes good morning members and thank you
for allowing me to speak again
um i first like to thank officers and
members for attorneys application to
committee so promptly
um we have been working positively with
the planning officers over the last
month
to come to a compromise on some of the
outstanding issues that were
raised in the previous committee um for
example we have swapped the location of
the four
h.a units so now accessed from bourne
terrace
and their social housing is pepper
potted in three different locations
all accessed from different roads
the revised plans also provide clarity
on a number of
issues such as the public away route
landscaping upgrades
that have been made to the northern
boundary to prevent any access onto the
onto the road uh the immunity area for
the apartments have increased and we've
upgraded the ha spec
to provide a washer dryer within the
apartments
we've also upgraded the path and on the
eastern boundary for a route that can be
easily used by
wheelchairs and and prams um hopefully
this provides some clarity on the points
referred at the last committee i'm happy
to answer some questions that obviously
raised previously
thank you uh members
have you any questions for the agent um
i think
councillor hinton was a uh council of
busby
i know one of you yeah hi sarah uh
thanks for that
uh can i say thank you for making the
changes that you have done but as you
probably guessed from the
discussions that we're having it's it's
the mix that is obviously of interest
i just i'm trying to get behind the
decision process that the developer
takes
in determining what mix they're going to
put into a development
so after the last committee meeting
did you and the developer have
discussions about
the mix
um we did we've had um internal
discussions within bellway and also
um with obviously jasmine and mark um
and it was felt that there wasn't a
policy justification for it um and
therefore we have
made the internal decision that we
wouldn't be changing the mix at this
late stage
just to provide some background on the
mix um
we obviously had a number of
pre-application discussions that took
place
before we submitted the application to
the council
it wasn't with jasmine it was a
different uh case officer
um at that stage obviously the mix was
discussed
um we discussed the bungalow
specifically and it was felt that
due to the fact that there is such a
significant distance between
the houses on bung uh road
sorry on hill and uh the houses on the
eastern boundary
that there wasn't a reason for there
wasn't an immunity
reason or overlooking reason or any any
real reason for the bungalows except
that it was previously
uh identified by pidgin
thank you vince the busby
yeah i mean again are you aware of the
the schma targets that uh that we're
having to comply with i am now yes
you've made that very
apparent in the last committee
okay um but again
it wasn't just necessarily switching
from bungalow
houses to bungalows or bungalows to
houses that was an issue it was the
two bedrooms and four bedrooms that was
uh a key as well
um in that you know we've got to provide
two-bedroom properties more than
four-bedroom yet you're providing
you know five times as many fours as
twos
again how does that how does the
developer
uh square that equation
um as previously said that you know
we we go through this process with at
the pre-app stage
and and if it's not raised by the
planning officer at that stage it's
something that
um that we just progressed through the
design process
um the the amount of two beds wasn't
raised previously
um perhaps it should have been um but it
wasn't
and so we have progressed with the three
and four bedroom houses we know that
ultimately that is what you know will
sell in an area
um and that's the aspirations for the
market
from a developer's point of view perhaps
rather than a council's point of view
but ultimately we're not going to build
units that will
end up just sitting there for years not
being sold so it's our aspirations
to to build and sell for the market
okay i think we can drag this out as
long as we like yeah
i think it's interesting that you think
that um 91
of your houses will um
sell better because they're we've got 66
of the population wanting one and two
bedroom houses but
that's your that's your problem but
thank you for asking my questions
thank you councillor busby uh councillor
osborne
your question i'm moot
no i can't hear you that's it that's it
i'm muted mr chairman thank you
just um just uh interesting sarah has
answered basically the question of
pepper potting
uh she has um and to her credit uh moved
them around a bit
but all i'm interested in is the block
of flats am i
am i am assured that or am i
under the impression that uh there are
no affordable housing within that block
of flats
and secondly does the height of those
flats
actually impact on the housing around it
which are
obviously going to be a lot smaller
smaller in height
thank you sarah um the
uh the hi is located within the flats
just so you're where the eight units are
within flats
um and in terms of the the height of the
block it's a part two story part three
story because of the way the
the lie of the lands it drops down on
that northern boundary so whilst it's
three-story
to the north it it dips down back to
two-story because of the
the height of the uh of the land there
it's on the slope so
it shouldn't have a dramatic effect you
know it will be viewed as a
two-story block predominantly
right just um just carrying on from that
if i may miss chairman um
i'm not uh i'm not happy about
affordable housing being all in one area
of flats
how many actually affordable properties
have you got in those flats
i believe there's eight eight uh
yeah it's very
if i want this with you um it's very
unusual to
divide up a block of flats into private
and social
it's just um it's just the maintenance
issue for it
excuse me for the um for the management
company
for the ha provider trying to
divide up stairwells and ownership it's
it's just a nightmare so
generally they're either all private all
hi within flats
fine yeah i i i quite understand that
and um
that has been the usual position with uh
with with developers actually coming
back to
say that uh the the the maintenance of
these
areas are that's why they're put in one
area so they can get at one
block all at once so you know so thank
you very much for that
and um as i say uh in in pasta beltway
uh i've always
done well in consultation so yeah i'm
i'm happy with that i'm not happy about
the height of that but there you go
thank you thank you councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um miss cornwall
at the previous meeting um you stated
that the
housing mix was determined by your other
developments across uh west suffolk i
think primarily
i don't think you got any around here uh
have you since that meeting and the
comments from that meeting about housing
mix done anything more to
ascertain from the actual needs of of
baby
how you can adjust the mix
um if i'm honest with you counseling no
i've not
um we've made an internal decision here
that we were happy with the mix
and that it would meet planning so we
haven't changed the mix
thank you councillor jameson
um sarah i just i'm looking at your
sustainability document regarding the
environmental
uh measures i believe you're putting gas
spoilers into the properties and i just
wondered why you've decided to do that
rather
than heat pumps of some
kind um if i'm honest with you we always
use
gas boilers um i can't remember last
time i used a heat pump but um it's
something i can raise with a technical
department but yeah
with gas boilers being phased uh in the
future i just wanted to
be better something more
environmentally better
uh i think it's just a new technology
that we haven't used before
we've used gas um boilers and it's just
what the purchaser
i think would be comfortable with rather
than a new technology that they're not
comfortable with
okay thank you any other questions
notes thank you
all right we'll move on um from the
agent we'll now go to the ward member
councillor jane gold you have five
minutes in which to address the
committee
thank you thank you very much chair
um thank you for giving me time to speak
this morning
i'm not sure i've got anything to add
it's more a case of me reiterating
really what western parish council have
said
um and it's the concerns about the
numbers of bungalows proposed
i'm aware of the fact that housing mix
is not a reserve matter because i i read
the documents even before hearing the
debate this morning
i'm simply expressing the concerns of
the residents in my ward
that the original layout indicated
bungalows that are not currently
provided
secondly i would like to draw your
attention to 414 the environmental
measures
um i'm pleased to hear that councillor
jameson has
mentioned this already as far as i can
see no changes have been made to these
measures
uh it would be good to see the
management of woodland and footpaths
secured by a condition if that's
possible
and it would be also useful to clarify
the net
biodiversity gain it says
and 414 right at the end measures to
encourage biodiversity
and so if possible it might be useful to
clarify that
that's all i've got to say at this point
thank you
thank you councillor girl i'll ask
jasmine uh whether those points have
been um
picked up and put into conditions
jasmine can you help on the points that
uh councillor gold has just brought to
our attention in terms of the
um the footpath in the management of the
woodland that would have been secured
with the full application that was the
original because it was a hybrid between
an outline planning application and a
full application so i think that has
been resolved
um and i think the maintenance and
management of the public open space and
the the woodland is
in the section 106. um in terms of the
sustainability measures as um i said
earlier in the presentation
the sustainability measures haven't been
changed between what was previously
presented to you
and now based on the fact that it has
been discharged in that sustainability
statement
um in a condition that was imposed on
the outline
um i'm sorry everything i can't
yeah um any questions members
to the ward member
no hands are up okay thank you
councillor gold we'll now move on to the
debate
i'll now open it up for debate now who
would like to start
there's no hands up yet
um uh councillor barrett
thank you chair i i thought
i think we we mustn't get too tied up
with the the lack of bungalows
um i i believe um
i think it's more more well there's two
issues with that there's the
there is a slight feeling of being
perhaps misled at some stage throughout
this process
um however that came about
um and it's difficult it's difficult to
to pin that in that one totally down
but um there's there's the the aspect of
bungalows yes our attractive option for
downsiding it's clearly what we need in
the the neighborhood uh to
the area um
and you know there is some provision for
that um but there are other
there are other deliveries here in terms
of affordable there's a
um it achieves the 35 percent uh
affordable which is
is a good aspect the the bungalows um
in terms of their height and proximity
to the
uh the already established houses on
born
born hill um there there is quite some
distance between them
so i don't have concerns about a lack of
bungalows in that respect
it's just a great shame not to see them
uh being delivered
but in other schemes very rarely in
other schemes do we see a
a huge number of bungalows being built
these days and so i think we have to
accept that actually um our aspirations
are not always shared shared um
for that um also
the the number of two beds against
number of four beds
um i think it's more more fundamental
really should
might be a focus on square footage of
the house
because many two-bedroom houses are just
not very
uh could not accommodate home working
very easily
especially if you know two two members
of the family
needed to work from home um
four beds does probably present that
opportunity and as we go forward we know
that
it's likely we're going to be um needing
to have that
flexibility in our homes um
so i i just i'm just
trying to to um to weigh up and be
reasonably realistic about what what
what what we should be expecting
um although naturally we're all very
disappointed about the bungalows
should that be a reason for for
for um concluding that this this should
be refused
i don't really think so i i
so i'll be interested to hear what other
what other views are
um thank you i think you i think you
have some very valid points there
um but also i think there's lessons for
us to learn
as members and and for officers to learn
on this so i think that will have been
very useful from that point of view
um but i do have counsellor busby next
thank you chair yeah
it would appear as though our hands are
tied we can't do anything about it
however the nppf which is the basic
guidelines to which we should comply
says under section 127 planning policies
and decisions should ensure that
developments
optimize the potential of the site to
accommodate and sustain
an appropriate amount and mix of
development
i mean these are the basic planning
ground rules that we should comply with
it doesn't say that has to be decided
upon
right up front or right at the very end
that's an underlying principle
that we should make decisions on
and this is a decision-making process so
i still think
i hear what the all the experts say
if i had enough money i'd back us with
an inspector
but i haven't so i can't and what
concerns me
is if we're a this principle
to we've got was it four and a half
thousand houses
that have been approved
uh maybe on outline planning
applications
how many of those are where the
developers to come to us and say oh yeah
we're going to put up
blocks of flats or we're going to put
five-bedroom houses and you can't do
anything about it
are we really saying that we can't have
any influence
over a planning decision on the mix of
housing once it's got past outline
planning
because i find that incredible thank you
um i understand and share your
frustration but i think the points have
been
answered but i will ask the um legal and
the officers if they wish to
respond to what you've just said before
i go to the next
member which is uh councillor mclaren um
officers mark
yes yes thank you chair yeah i mean i i
do
i do hear and understand what counselor
busby's saying but i would hope that the
um
the relevant paragraphs in the report
make it clear what what the response to
that would be
um i would also say that hear what
you're saying about the
nose but you would have to conclude that
even without the bungalows
which had been promised and dangled
there like a carrot um the scheme is
acceptable anyway um it wasn't the
amount of bungalows that made it okay
last time
that that was just something that made
it look even better if you like for
members
um the the two-story houses don't
produce overlooking or loss of light or
any of that sort of thing so
from a development management
perspective that they're acceptable
so um and in terms of the the permission
that councillor busby responded to
it's got a permission it was the outline
permission that that's that's when he
got permission and these are the reserve
matters of that permission
of which mix is not won so it's it's the
same answer to the
same sort of question understanding
totally frustration but i hope members
would come away with the
conclusion that the scheme is all right
anyway it's just that you're
disappointed you haven't got more
bungalows
thank you um councillor mclaren uh
thank you chair i just want to make a
comment
about pepper potting this comes up
we've had it in a few applications
and when the applicants come back
with a revised plan you still
find a concentration of affordable
housing
in a particular area and to me
looking at the one today yes they've
separated them
but human nature is um
unpredictable i just find it
unacceptable
that affordable housing is still
sort of corralled in a certain area away
from the majority
of the uh the plan thank you
i think you have a valid point there but
we are where we are with the
application in front of us thank you
i'll see if jasmine's got any comments
to give you on that
jasmine um
yeah i suppose the only thing i can sort
of comment on
um is that technically they are
considered as three clusters um
and they are all under the the 15
dwelling threshold
um which is in you know our
supplementary planning documents on
guidance for affordable housing um
that's
all i can really say i understand
obviously they are all to the western
side of the site
but if i could come in chair as well um
we have to think about the registered
social landlords that they actually if
you take the planner's dream of
full integration i mean pepper potting
is probably a misleading phrase because
it suggests
an affordable a market an affordable
amount you know like that that is
sprinkled and actually the reality is
that
uh bridges social landlords don't like
working that way they do like the
housing in groups
so it's it's never going to be sprinkled
across but it it's
preferable to be in blocks here and
there so this scheme
has moved towards that it could have
been better but it does have it in three
distinct blocks
in a way which um a registered social
landlord would be happy to work with
thank you i can see the look on your
face mary but thank you
um councillor osborne
councillor osborne you've got your hand
up and you're still muted
yeah i'm just saying yeah he's getting
me handed to go on to the uh
would you hear you thank you
mr chairman um the one thing with
as we always say is um the design of the
affordable housing
i hope will take uh
will not look any different to the other
housing that is there because that's
what determines
the look of a development and brings
could bring the development down
into what we've had in a lot lot
earlier years the other the other
position i just wanted to make um and
i i stand to be corrected here that the
section 106 requirements um
have we am i led to believe that the
heads and tails of this has not been
completed so therefore
the monies that would be contributed
towards uh
open space and schools and uh whatever
else the monies go to
has not yet been um been been
set up am i correcting that
i've i'll go to jasmine but i think the
uh the last meeting we were given
assurances that
um uh the materials were going to be the
same but jasmine can you help on those
two points that kensal osbourne has
brought out
or mark yes um of course so
they are completely tenure-blind units
um
in materials architectural features
everything
um so you will not be able to tell that
they are affordable houses
um in terms of the section 106 and the
contributions
that has to be dealt with outlined so
that has already been signed and secured
thank you yeah thank you for that it's
only that normally when you see
uh uh when you see the full application
and the reserve matters
you see the amounts that actually have
been
uh put within those areas so anyway
thank you very much
thank you councillor parker
um yeah thank you very much chair um
good morning um
and forgive me chair if this has already
been answered but um
councillor hinton alluded to it um at
the outset actually and jasmine
i think you said you were going to go
away and find them but if members were
minded to support this application
and approve the recommendation as set
out
what are those conditions eight eleven
sixteen eighteen twenty eight thirty one
thirty two and twenty two
well done i've made a note of them good
shall i um i have got the document up
now if that's useful yeah
yes if you can give the answers to
councillor parker and the rest of the
committee thank you
bear with me i'll just get it up for you
can you all see my screen just
okay um right so condition eight
is this one here
so this relates to the external
materials which they have submitted to
us can you read it out to us i can see
it but perhaps some
can't but just read that paragraph so
prior to above ground construction
details of the external materials of the
buildings shall be submitted to
and approved in writing by the local
planning authority
the development shall be undertaken in
accordance with the agreed details
thank you um then
there with me i've just got to write so
11 is the next one
so 11 is before development is commenced
details shall be submitted to and
approved in writing by the local
planning authority showing the means to
prevent the discharge of surface water
from the development onto the highway
the approved scheme shall be carried out
in its entirety before the access is
first used and shall be retained
thereafter in its approved form
thank you then we've got condition 16 is
the next one
so before the development is commenced
details of the areas to be provided for
the parking of vehicles
shall be submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
the approved scheme shall be carried out
in its entirety before the development
is brought into use
and shall be retained thereafter and
used for no other purpose
thank you we've got 18
prior to above-ground construction a
plan indicating the positions design
materials and type of boundary
treatments to be planted
and or erected along the boundary of the
site with the public highway
which is the a137 shall be submitted to
and approved in writing by the local
planning authority
this boundary treatment shall be
completed in accordance with details and
a timetable to be firstly agreed in
writing with the local planning
authority and shall be maintained
thereafter
you 28
is no development should take place
until a long-term monitoring
and maintenance plan in respect of
contamination including a timetable of
monitoring
and submission of reports to the local
planning authority shall be submitted to
and approved in writing by the local
planning authority
unless otherwise agreed in writing with
the local planning authority
reports are specified in the approved
plan including details of any
necessary contingency action arising
from the monitoring
shall be submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
any necessary contingency measures shall
be carried out in accordance with
details in the approved reports
on completion of the monitoring
specified in the plan a final report
demonstrating that all long-term
remediation works
have been carried out and confirming
that remedial targets have been achieved
shall be submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
thank you then 31
prior to the commencement of development
a surface water drainage scheme
shall be submitted to and approved in
writing by the local planning authority
the scheme shall be in accordance with
the approved flood risk assessment and
include
dimensioned plans and drawings of the
surface water drainage scheme
modelling shall be submitted to
demonstrate that the surface water
runoff will be restricted to a rate
suitable for the highway culvert
underneath the a137 for all events up to
the critical
one in 100 year rainfall events
including climate change as specified in
the flood risk assessment
modeling the surface water drainage
scheme to show that the attenuation
slash
infiltration features will contain the 1
in 100
year rainfall event including climate
change
modelling of the surface water
conveyance network in the 1 in 30-year
rainfall event
to show no ground flooding and modelling
of the volumes of any above ground
flooding from the pipe network
in a 100 year climate change rainfall
event
along with topographic plans showing
where the water will flow and be stored
to ensure no flooding of buildings or
off-site flows
topographical plans depicting all
exceedance flow paths and demonstration
that flows will be routed to areas of
least vulnerability and will be
and will not flood buildings on or off
the site
and if they are to be directed to the
surface water drainage system then the
potential additional rates and volumes
of surface water must be included
within the modelling of the surface
water system the scheme shall be fully
implemented as approved
thank you very much the final one
is 32 prior to commencement of
development
details of the implementation
maintenance and management of the
surface water drainage scheme shall be
submitted to and approved in writing by
the local planning authority
the strategy shall be implemented and
thereafter maintained
in accordance in accordance with the
approved details
thank you i think that's all been very
helpful um
councillor parker
yeah it has indeed thank you very much
uh jasmine for that uh very fulsome
explanation so um i mean chair
if if i may i i've got the greatest
respect as as ever for
um you know the impassioned points that
uh the councillor busby puts forward and
he does so because
you know he genuinely cares and and it's
right that uh that we do question but
but i think that um mr russell um
has hit the nail on the head really um
in the last thing he said
in there and yes of course it is
disappointing um
that we've had bungalows dangled before
us but
essentially is the application that
before us is it um
is it so objectionable um uh so as to
make members
um you know not approve this application
and for me
personally um it isn't if if we
uh if we take all of the you know the
legalities to one side and we deal with
what is actually in front of us here
is the application that stands before us
acceptable and i have to say we've seen
far more controversial applications that
sit before us and so taking it
in its um you know taking it as it is as
a planning application um
i i can't object to this um chair so
on that basis um i would like to make a
proposal that actually we accept
the officer's recommendation as it as
it's laid out
in in the report thank you thank you do
i have a sex
counselor barrett yes i'd like to
uh second that um yeah it's a good point
um and and one at the back of my mind
too that
it's overall it's a scheme and if if we
set aside everything else
that we know about the the previous um
details
and just look at it at it um simply as
what's proposed now
we we may well have concluded you know
and and
and seen it in a different light
favorably
thank you so you're second today uh
we'll we'll carry on
i have three more members hopefully
there'll be new points rather than dwell
on some of the old ones
i've got councillor hinton followed by
councillor jameson followed by
councillor ayers
councillor hinton thank you mr chairman
just a quick point on those
um uh conditions thanks very much indeed
for reading them out to us jasmine
uh especially all the sort of legalese
that's included in them which
means that there's a paragraph which
actually says absolutely nothing
which is quite interesting but one thing
that does come out
is that the susceptibility of this site
two
problems concerning surface water
drainage and potential flooding
uh is there a subsequent scheme in place
for this site because no mention of that
has been made anywhere
um presumably that would have been incur
included in somewhere and should it
therefore be included in any
recommendations that we put forward
good time adjustment so in terms of
um surface water flooding events
everything like that they are all
assessed by the local lead flood
authority which is suffolk county
council
um they are the ones that do you know
they look at all the flood risk
assessments
which were submitted with the outline um
those conditions are pretty much lifted
from what they
have recommended to us um so we don't
alter them in any way
in terms of um all of the mitigation
measures
um they are completely assessed by
suffolk county council floods and water
and
as planning officers you know we are not
the experts
in any way to do with flooding and
things like that so
we do rely on them to provide us with
um the advice and guidance on what needs
to happen with the site and
as far as this goes um suffolk county
council floods and water haven't raised
any objection
um to the reserve matters and to those
food conditions that they wish to
discharge
thank you okay mr german if i could just
come back
on that and say so what is the answer
yes there is a sud scheme or no there
isn't because i'm afraid when it comes
to suffolk county council and their
flood assessment i'm not i don't have
that much confidence having been the
council's representative on the flood
and emergency committee
uh panel for some time when uh an
exercise
showed that the concrete wall that was
was recommended and built along the
front of
uh ipswich docks to keep flood water out
was a potential problem in it if the
water ever got behind it they could
never get it out again
um because it was a solid concrete wall
what is what is the actual suds
arrangement is the one or isn't the one
jasmine um so i'm just
having a look through um the conditions
that are on the outline
and condition 33 is actually
that the development um hereby permit
shall not be occupied until details of
all sustainable urban drainage system
components and pipes networks have been
submitted
um so i think it is
it's there it would be coming at a later
date though
thank you you're
unmoved please councillor hinton sorry
mr chairman
so this was uh a condition
from the original grant of planning
permission and
isn't covered by this reserve matters
it's something that's still outstanding
uh yeah if i may um yes i mean we get
this situation where you've had an
outline and you've got reserve
matters and sometimes the conditions and
the reserve match can cross over a
little bit
um for argument's sake because i don't
think condition 33 has been discharged
yet
um the applicant could find that they're
in a bit of a mess if they don't do that
you'll notice that it's actually um
expressed as prior to occupation
um so that they need to sort it out
basically
um it could affect that the layout at
which point they'd have to come back to
committee so one would hope that they've
got something up their sleeve and they
know what they're doing
it will fall on them if it doesn't work
out properly
thank you councillor jameson
uh thanks chad um in terms of addressing
climate change by design looking at both
cs15 and the mpps it states that new
development should address
climate change by incorporating or
producing sources of renewable or low
carbon energy
and looking at the company's
sustainability statement
i can see no mention of solar panels and
as i said earlier they're putting in
gas-fired boilers when a lot of
development companies are already
putting in um
heat pumps and it's just um quite
disappointing
really
um i don't know if there's any comments
on that i i wasn't aware of that
ballers were being banned by a certain
time
but i think that chair in the um in the
report in the amended paragraphs i mean
that that
these measures have been looked at by a
sustainability officer and been
discharged as one of the conditions
i know the disappointment could have
been better but they have these have
been discharged these matters right
thank you kenzler ayers
thank you chair i was just going to come
in and second that
but i just like to say i totally agree
with the comments by councillor barrett
and councillor parker and um i would
also
be happy to prove thank you thank you
uh right if there's no new points that
anybody wants
to bring up and there's no hands up i
can't james and i think you've left your
hand up
yeah there's no new hands then i should
go to the vote
it has been proposed and seconded but
before i do that
i'll ask the chief planning officer to
to read out
um the proposal on the table please
thank you chair um i'll just open that
up and basically it hasn't changed
from the um from the agenda so it's it's
recommending approval
with conditions which um i will now
refer to
i mean they're only they're on the
agenda so it's it's that basically
thank you uh
cancer sorry um rob will you know do a
roll call
because it's been proposed and seconded
we're no go to the vote thank you
thank you chair so if members could
please respond
with fought against or abstain so
counselor suit airs four
that's a melanie barrett four
councillor peter beer reluctantly four
councillor david busby yeah sorry i
can't against
counselor john hinton i can't either
against
castle lee jameson against
councilman mary mclaren four
castle adrian osborne disappointingly
for
because allison owen very reluctantly
but for
casa lee parker yeah just finishing
four sorry thank you counselor parker
um for um
councillor steven reluctantly
four thank you chair i make that eight
votes to three
carried mr dupree do you
um yeah yeah so if you can hear me i
think i've got some skateboarders going
past my house if sorry for the noise um
yes i i i agree you'll count mr demarco
michael
um eight four three against thank you
then that is carried thank you very much
um now do you want to comfort break for
uh about seven eight minutes come back
please seven o'clock
okay and then we'll take the um a
lebanon one
okay so come for break we'll resume
again at 11 o'clock
thank you welcome back everybody
would you know like to conduct a role
call um
robert thank you champ so
we'll just make sure everyone is back so
if you could please respond
um to let me know that you are in the
meeting still so
counselor airs yes i'm here council
barrett
yes i am cancer beer present
counselor busby yeah present casper
hinton
president councillor jemison yeah here
councilman mclaren president osborne
president council owen
very present council parker
present council plum president
and two ward members of council arthi
and councillor mayberry
brilliant thank you we are all present
and there are no public speakers
for this application thank you i will
now ask the
uh sorry we're now at tender peace
common room
uh lavender okay and the case offer
africa
would you like to take us through this
application
please thank you chair i'll just
put the presentation up
yes we can see oh yeah now you've got it
okay can you see the first slide yeah
full plan and application
yep yep thank you so the proposal before
us today
is for full planning application for the
erection of a single story front
extension
and external alterations to 10 to piece
common room in lavenham
the application is before committee
today because the site is owned by baber
district council
um and leased by lavenden parish council
the applicant
so the application site is situated
within the village of lavenham
it is also been sorry to interrupt you
um overall
uh but on my screen i've got my picture
come up in the corner of your
um slide i i don't know if anybody else
can see that
if you can't then that's great yeah i
can see you there as well
hang on
if you share your screen slightly
differently it should get
it should change it around so if you
stop sharing
okay and then if you do instead of share
um screen if you share or win share
specific program of powerpoint that
should
um solve that okay i'll try that
is that better yep that's yes oh
have you got that back yes slightly
we're on
no it's good okay that's fine it's just
me can see it then
um yeah sorry so the application site is
located within the village of lavenham
and it is also within the settlement
boundary
the orange indicates where the common
room is situated
10 to piece is the residential estate
indicated here it com comprises
a sheltered housing scheme amongst
other dwellings
it is to the north of the b-1071 which
is the main road passing through lavanam
um
okay so this is the site location plan
submitted with the application with the
red line indicating
um where the common room is located um
the common room is situated within the
southwestern terrace block of tent piece
comprising numbers
9-17
this shows the aerial map um you can see
these terrace blocks here are 10 to
piece
the parking for the site they're
parking in the turning head here but you
can also see that cars park on the
highway here
the tree belt to the north of the site
is protected
under a tree preservation order
and you can see the church to the
southwest
so the church saint peter's and st
paul's church
um to the south west is grade one listed
um they're also grade two and grade two
star properties
listed fronting the b1071
you can as i said previously the site is
within the built up area boundary which
is
illustrated in brown on the map and the
application site is within
lavanam conservation area
and turning to the block plan the red
line plan illustrates
where the front extension will be
situated
the grey here is the parking area
with a grassed area to the front of the
site
there are also external alterations
proposed to the rear elevation
shown here and i'll discuss those on
further slides
this is the existing elevation of
just the common room area of that
terrace block
the rear the external alterations um
listed in the
description of development include this
single access door
and steps which are proposed to be
removed and
bricked up and the front extension
will be located where the free windows
and single access door is on the front
elevation
the existing materials for the building
include
buff brick with black cladding to the
first floor
and it has a peg tile roof the floor
plan
illustrates the current layout
so the proposal as previously mentioned
it's to remove
the door and steps and brick up with
matching brick work the front extension
is for a mono pitched lean to
extension it will protrude 1.9
meters from the front elevation and be
5.3 meters in length
the roof will extend a further 1.65
meters to provide a covered area
for this access doorway here
it'll have four windows to the front
with
one on either side and two v-lux windows
also proposed
in terms of materials um there will be
brick work and cladding to match the
existing building
and it will have a slate roof
this is the proposed floor plan you can
see the dimensions of the extension
shown here and the dashed line on the
floor plan shows the existing floor plan
and where
the common room is currently situated
you can see the access door will be
removed and there are some internal
alterations which are not subject
to planning here are some photos of the
site
this is is numbers 9 to 17 10 to pieces
this block along here
you can see the parking area here and
the common room is
central in the photograph
just a zoomed in version of the current
common room
frontage you can see the free windows
and access door here
the front elevation facing west you can
see the grade one
listed church in the background which is
screened by
some mature vegetation to that boundary
and this is a view um from
the common room facing the car park
finally the rear elevation um
the doorway which is to be removed is
behind
this um kind of trellis
boarding here um so a picture is
quite difficult but it will replicate
kind of the doorway looks
similar to to this with the steps here
behind them
um from the since writing the report
the consultation period has now expired
we have received two consultation
responses
from one from economic development and
one from
the heritage team both of which can be
found in the table papers which i
believe you received yesterday
um the economic development team
chose to provide no comments and the
heritage team concluded that the
proposal
would have no harm to the setting of the
listed building
both the grade one listed church and the
properties along
the b10 71 and
the character and appearance of the
conservation area
on that basis and compliance with local
plan policies my recommendation is for
approval
um with the standard time frame and
approved documents conditions
thank you thank you very much overall
uh right i'll save the members got any
points to clarification i've just got a
couple
um the roof lights that you show in
slide
eight yep does that open into a large
common room or is there a corridor
because when you shoe slide 11 and 12 it
looked like there was a corridor behind
that i can't see why they've got roof
lights in that front little bit
no i believe they're just over kind of
the extension part here
so they're not shown on this plan but
they will just be
so it does open up into a larger room
yeah so it's one large room
that makes sense to me now thank you
uh members uh councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman just just a quick
question
i can understand why those roof lights
are there because obviously the the main
part of the common room will
get a bit dark with that stuck out the
front there
my question is to do with the rear
access the rear door
uh once you brick that up there's only
one one way in
and out of these premises if this is for
sheltered housing namely sort of elderly
or infirm
person persons um one access surely is a
little bit of a risk what the health and
safety say about that
um so we don't consult um kind of the
health and safety that
that would be a separate matter um
obviously each kind of section of the
sheltered housing scheme
i mean this one is only for the common
room
a kitchen area it's kind of a communal
space and obviously each
then apartment um or kind of dwelling
house has its own access
um i i think as la hinton has a point
there only one excess in the
escape route they're in there
um mark can you help out on this
yeah thanks thanks chad i think we've
possibly strayed into into building
regulations
little here in terms of i don't think
fire escape whatever you're thinking
about um
i'm also not fully convinced that it
would need planning permission anyway
i'm not going to definitely say that but
it seems like a minor matter
um which i would ask didn't obstruct you
in your decision-making process
well i don't know if it's a minor matter
with blocking up a doorway and only
having one exit
uh i don't share counselor hindens
concerns here um councillor hinton did
you want to come back
yes i think as this is a baber property
as well uh it would not show the council
in very
very good light if at some future
occasion there was a necessity for
getting people out of there in a hurry
and there was only one means of doing it
i can't also see all right i understand
there are going to be some minor
internal alterations but why are you
breaking up the back door anyway
is it so that you can just got more wall
space in which case
um surely there is an opportunity to
produce an extra access somewhere
i think this is obviously a decision
that the the operator has made
if you want us to feed back to our
estates department
that um as the as the owner
of the building um councils have asked
why are you breaking it up we can do
that but um in terms of
a planning authority making decision um
the fact we own the site obviously
should be immaterial um i can see
councillor
mayberry has put her hand up um
i if it's on this point that we're
trying to get clarification on
i i think i can let you speak is that
correct
ian uh yeah
member wants to ask a question to the
presenting officer i think have we
allowed that in the past respect we have
um
yeah i i think she may have
some comment on the um uh
this rear door uh and it obviously
is a concern nothing legally wrong and i
think i understand that i'd like to
allow it if it's specifically on this
point councillor maybe
mr chairman um it is um i have
intimate knowledge of this building um
if you will see from the proposed floor
plan in front of you there is a stairway
through a corridor
from the external door um
which is one exit otherwise the
properties
are on an upper floor
at that point which has a long outdoor
corridor which is completely open
to the elements apart from a roof which
provides
also escape routes in two positions that
i well definitely one position
that i can remember so there are exits
and you can't actually see that's that
is the open corridor for the top flaps
and to the i'm not very good at this but
as you're looking at it to the right
there is another external staircase
if that helps you at all and the rear
door
is to be bricked in to allow
for a much larger kitchen because at the
moment
if one person is in the kitchen i think
i must
stop you there thank you i think you
clarified that point i think councillor
hinton this is something that we may
have to pick up as we go through the
debate
um because i think it is important um
is there any other questions to um
the officer for clarification
no thank you right then we'll move on to
the um public speakers which don't have
any so i'll now ask for the ward members
to speak we have two um you both have
five minutes each that's councillor
alfie and
councillor mabry um well i think ladies
first
unless councillor arfy wants to go first
uh councillor mabry you very much
mr chairman um for allowing me this
opportunity to speak
the planning application for alterations
to the common room at tenth piece
levenum
i have lived breathed and worked on
over the last four years and finally
hopefully it will come to fruition i'm
delighted that this planning application
is before the planning committee
within baber owned properties we enjoy a
variety of homes and facilities
and the opportunity to improve enlarge
make accessible currently there is no
accessible ground floor lavatory and
visually appealing is a great vision
for the district as a whole
to reiterate that baby district council
are open to all and will listen to the
needs of residents
the parish council at lavanam have put a
great deal of work
into the use of an existing property
working alongside different groups
within the village
and i thank them their chairman
councillor carol reeve
and their lead counsellor on community
engagement councillor doreen twitchard
for never giving up on a plan to improve
the lives of others
babe officers as consulted under
community
issues have supported this application
as they to see the wisdom of such a
combined use for a building
to improve the lives of others
this week has seen a national day for
alzheimer's
and anyone with a connection for someone
with this disease
would have been heartened to have the
profile of sufferers and their carers
increased
the planning application for tenta peace
will in fact help
local residents with this disease as the
level and
dementia group meets when regulations
allow
at this address residents along with
other groups
many of which are vulnerable and older
will have
if this application is approved a safe
accessible warm and inviting
as well as intimate place to meet to
pass the time of day
to socialize and to ease the trauma of
loneliness
i fully support this application and i
urge the planning committee to approve
the application
this morning as recommended by officers
and thank you thank you ansler mabry
members do you have any questions for
the
award speaker
counselor hinton your hand is up
apologies mr chairman i'll bring it down
all right thank you
there's no hands up thank you councillor
mabry uh there's no questions to you so
i'll go
to your fellow councillor award member
which is councillor clive arthy
councillor arthi you have five minutes
wish to address the committee
thank you chairman yes i won't be that
long um firstly there's just a slight
correction to avril's presentation she
referred to the b-1071
um as being the main road passing
through lavender
unfortunately it's not the a1141 also
passes through lavender i wish it didn't
but it does
um okay um just on
um the application as you will probably
know from the sill papers
i presented to cabinet the proposals are
also
part of a current sill bid
they are acceptable in planning terms um
and
they haven't proved to be at all
contentious as you can see in the papers
the application is only before you
because of the council's interest and
i also support the application thank you
thank you very much councillor alfie
members is any questions to the award
member counselor arthi
no hands are up thank you very much
right we'll now move to debate
i'll open it up who would like to start
uh councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um just really i i
would uh
like to propose we accept this uh uh
application
uh the officer's recommendation for this
application uh
but i would just like like a note to be
made that we
look at the access
accessibility of this common room uh
i take all that councilor mabry said
about the upstairs landing and its
outside
access and ability to get out etc but
i'm concerned about people in this one
common room only having one entry and
exit point
and they are both the same uh bricking
up the back door might improve the
the kitchen layout etc but it does
rather restrict the opportunities to get
out of the building
if anything should happen in that
kitchen yes there's plenty of access
points for the
people upstairs to get out having got
the notification that there's something
going on in that kitchen
but not for the people in the common
room there's only the one
one way in and it's the same way out so
i would like to propose this
recommendation with that reservation
that
if it is looked at by building regs or
by foreign safety or whoever
needs to approve the overall use of the
room
thank you um i'll check to see if we can
do that
um first of all um
mark or avril i don't know whether this
would be acceptable um it's really yes
or no
you seem to be asking for an informative
which is fairly harmless
they can be added to the foot of the
decision notice thank you
because i do share council hinton's
concerns on that uh but councillor ayers
i'm looking for a secondhand your hand
came up
yes yes i'd be quite happy to um
second that because um i live in a
complex
quite similar for people that are over
55
um but in these recent times because we
do have an area outside
for those with alzheimer's or any other
problems that has been so useful
and looking at the um the pictures of
that obviously
they could commune you know communicate
with each other outside
and i think it's really really important
and i would definitely second it
a little bit worried about the access
but i think it's brilliant thank you
thank you very much thank you uh
councillor osborne
yeah thank you um thank you mr chairman
i understand it's sheltered housing
am i led to believe that there will be
war this is a warden controlled area
um because um some uh
uh some of these properties have
had their wardens uh taken away but
this is a fairly new area so i would
have thought there would be one there am
i correct
can somebody help us on this we used to
have them i know
i can help on that oh yeah when i ran
and spoke to the parents
i'll just introduce you so that the
public know
counselor um jan osborne
um whose um portfolio
this is jen well thank you mr chairman
yes just to clarify councillor adrian
osborne's query
uh they do have a uh a warden on site
not 24 7
but they do have access to to a warden
as the scheme is sheltered
hope that answers his question thank you
i'm sure he'll come back if it doesn't
okay thank you very much all right thank
you
um i've got two hands still up john
hinton and suez i don't know whether
they were left up
yes sorry um you got another question
yes go on
no sorry i'd take it down i haven't
no it's still up but anyway i know
you're not uh there's no other hands up
then
yeah just bear with me that's
my computer's just
right uh like it's been proposed and
seconded
um i'm going to uh go to the vote now
and ask
robert to do the roll call
i've been proposed and seconded thank
you chair so
if i will i will now ask members to
please respond with
for against or abstain so counselor sue
ayers
four council melanie barrett
four councillor peterborough
four
that's the lee parker oh
and council stephen plum four
thank you chair i make that unanimously
carried
um yes i agree um chairman mr carmichael
unanimously
unanimously carried thank you thank you
very much that
that has been approved uh we've now come
to the end of the meeting members
i'll just remind you the date and time
of the next meeting which is scheduled
for wednesday the 7th of october
at 9 30. thank you all for your
attendance today
thank you members of the public and the
speakers
and all have a good day
you